construction of the North stream to
pipeline is already well underway but
the fate of the project lies in the
balance
EU members have not yet agreed on how to
proceed and Germany and France in
particular appear to be at odds over
regulation this is what's at stake the
pipeline would transport gas from Russia
to Germany via the Baltic Sea the
project in its current form is operated
by Russian state energy company Gazprom
and that's exactly what critics
including the United States and
seemingly France object to the
dependency from Russian gas will
increase drastically with this new
pipeline and that's the reason why they
constructed and it contradicts obviously
the European goals not only of the
energy union but in the future we will
see less gas demand because of climate
policy and this is the reason why this
pipeline is completely unaccountable
decide whether to extend the bloc's
energy rules to Gazprom if they do so
the company would no longer be allowed
to both operate the pipeline and handle
sales meaning the project in its current
form at least could go up in smoke
let's get more on this story we are
joined by Brussels bureau chief max
Hoffman and Hans branch our political
correspondent here in Berlin welcome to
both of you and Max I'd like to begin
with you because this announcement by
France it's essentially a move against
Germany do we know why Paris is taking
this step we haven't heard an official
explanation yet from the French but it
appears that the arguments are mainly
political and they've been heard before
they're not new France wasn't really in
favor of this project in the past either
but they stuck with Germany the problem
though is that it's really splitting the
European Union between East and West
countries like Poland like the Baltic
states have always been very much
against this project because they fear
more Russian influence in the European
Union they feel like they're being
bypassed and so this would be one of the
arguments some say it might be a little
revenge even from the French government
because I gonna Mack oh really didn't
wholeheartedly
for the projects that reminder where my
call had for the European Union most of
them had a slow painful death in the
back rooms of Brussels Berlin and and
and also Berlin and the last one is but
that is we don't know anything about
that yet a factual base is that there
might be some commercial interest
because France already has some
liquefied natural gas terminals and is
intending to build more so they might be
able to receive some of that gas coming
from the United States okay but you know
regardless of the motivations if we look
at the move overall Hans I mean one
newspaper here is calling it a disaster
for German diplomacy at the EU has
Berlin misjudged the situation is I
think one has to say that German if the
diplomacy has misjudged that's this
project North stream too we have to say
there is one pipeline already in place
North stream one in exactly the same
places as a second line being built and
that's been pushed through with a lot of
power diplomacy from the side of the
Germans for several years now and I
think in the end they have misjudged two
things they have misjudged the extent of
the resistance within the European Union
and especially now from France the
coordination with France seems to have
been lacking or not will not done well
enough and the other thing that the
Germans I think I've misjudged is the
resistance from the United States the
pressure coming from the United States
since Donald Trump took over as
president that's been massive not only
on Germany but also in other countries
in the region on the European Union as a
whole and I think the results of that
are what we are seeing now let's talk a
little bit more about that pushback from
the United States because we know that
the US ambassador to Germany also
Richard Grinnell said that the Nord
Stream essentially makes Germany
dependent on Russia the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel responded to
that and here's what she had to say
let's have a listen
combien up English careful we become
dependent on Russia because of this gas
pipeline I say no
if we diversify at the same time Germany
will expand its gas terminals with
regard to liquefied gas
this that means that we don't want to
make ourselves dependent on Russia under
any circumstances but Russia was a
source of gas during the Cold War and it
will remain so today without as entering
into one-sided dependence so that is how
the German Chancellor is responding to
her critics Hans is that enough I think
in the end not I think that does not
really address the concerns of many
people we have to see behind this there
is some commercial interest from the
United of the United States a lot of gas
is being produced there and the United
States is hoping to make Europe a major
client for selling that gas but behind
that is also a dirty geo threat geo
strategic thought consideration
concerning Ukraine a lot of gas is going
through Ukraine at the moment if this
gas bypasses Ukraine Russia has a handle
to put a lot of pressure on Ukraine and
that's obviously been a reason for
sanctions against Russia in recent years
a reason for a lot of tension between
Europe the United States and Russia
so this pipeline could ratchet up that
tension and that's also one of the
concerns of the critics of this pipeline
max what do you see as the impact on
French German ties because I mean this
has you know been an access of strength
for Europe until now in the beginning it
looked like ammonia made my call and I
got America would be the new Dream Team
in the European Union but slowly many
observers noticed that the two weren't
aligned on the political goals and this
is probably the the biggest blow to that
friendship ever since it comes at it at
a time just two and a half weeks after
they signed a new friendship treaty the
follow up to the Alizee treaty in in
Aachen and I was there and it says in
the treaty that both would now try to
align on big EU projects before
decisions this has obviously not worked
here and at the same time we don't know
if that's a coincidence or not a minor
in my call will not go to the Munich
Security Conference where he was
scheduled to appear together with Angela
Merkel so this might not be the new low
point of German French freckle
German friendship in the European Union
but it seems to be the new low point of
those two going forward it'll be
interesting to see if they if they work
this out but really this project is so
important for the Germans it's been
going on for so long with so much
resistance that it's really hard to see
how they will overcome this blow in the
new future max Hoffman in Brussels
Hans Brunt in Berlin thank you so much
to both of you